a statement from Anthony blinken the U.S
Secretary of State the sense of a
ceasefire about it he has said that the
Sudanese armed forces and the
paramilitary group the rapid support
forces have agreed to implement a
nationwide ceasefire starting at
midnight local time that would be 11 p.m
UK time this is according as I said to
Anthony blinken who said this in a
statement the United States urged both
sides to immediately and fully uphold
the ceasefire in Sudan worth remembering
that ceasefires have come and gone
possibly this is to allow foreign
Nationals from all sorts of Nations to
get out of the country who knows the
published figure for UK Nationals is 400
that rises to 4 000 for dual citizens
um Andrew Mitchell in the comments
suggesting that if you have a British
passport you'd be expected to be treated
in the same way and the foreign office
suggesting it's received 2 000
registered Communications so that is the
very latest we will see if that
ceasefire holes so a 72 hour ceasefire
that is the prospect for starting at
midnight local time in Sudan